I have Hayden and his cousin over for
the next two weeks for me so I'm in I'm
in the work light mode right now one of
the things that's been on my mind
work-life balance a lot of people ask
about it a lot of parents or students
how do i balance school how do i balance
a relationship how do i balance having
kids and for me again everything comes
down to my schedule so I know I've got
Hayden with me for the next two weeks I
could easily put him in some kind of day
camp just be with him in the evenings
but that's not what I want to do that's
not the father that I want to be and so
I was going to call the only other call
I had today was with someone on my team
he came up with some really cool ideas
that I need to work on for my my my
business basically and I told them I'm
gonna have to sit on that I loved it I'm
so excited by the idea I'm so excited
but I gotta sit on it for two weeks
because I'm in worklight mode right now
because I want to spend the time with my
son and so just understand away what
your priorities are and then making a
schedule that fits them and then not
worrying about the judgement of other
people this is what I want to do this is
what being Evan Carmichael looks like
right now and that will change you know
in in three months or six months or
maybe you think maybe you think I
shouldn't be doing the IG lives at 12:30
maybe I should spend the whole day with
my son maybe you think I should be
putting him with my parents and he
spends time with his grandparents and
and I can work during the day so I can
get my get closer to my mission I don't
really care what you think right it's
like this is what I want to do this is
what this is what the balance looks like
for me and I think understanding what
that looks like for you and then dealing
with the judgment nobody the people
around you or not always can support
what you want to do whatever your
version of balance in July of 2018 looks
like right now as long as you're happy
with it that's the only thing that
matters and the people around you aren't
happy with it you do not get happy by
doing their version of balance
you never will and so most the time I'm
working hard hard hard hard hard hard
hard worked light mode is as a downshift
for me that's actually super difficult
to do but I also don't want to you know
summer is important summer is a time
that we can bond I don't want to lose
this time and so this is how I have
adjusted and I'm happy with it and so I
thought I would share because I know a
lot of you guys are going through
similar issues of kids and relationships
in schools and how to balance everything
you put in your schedule you create with
the balance that looks amazing for you
and then you live that forgetting about
what other people think about what your
version balance looks like question I
was I wanted you because I mean working
going to meetings how do you deal with
the guilt when you have your your son
with you there's so many of with that
you're not achieving you feel some kind
of you oh I love that question I think
it's something else that we all think
about and go through I try to project
out of the current moment I don't feel
guilty right now that I'm not with them
making slamming and I'm with you guys
and I go through that process in my
schedule I think when you feel guilty is
when you haven't thought thought things
through and so I know for the next two
weeks I'm gonna be with Hayden some days
where I'm still gonna get work done like
on Monday I have to go to TDS I'm still
gonna mentor Alex I'm still gonna mentor
Lily and so we're planning out what is
when they look like for him at TDS he's
gonna come with me I'm not I'm not
giving him somebody else he's coming
with me and we're gonna do some fun
Monday's the heaviest work that
basically I have and everything else is
pretty much superlight I don't feel
guilty because I fought my way through
it I planned on doing this live
Instagram hangout and if I couldn't make
it because I had to go somewhere else
I would cancel it I wouldn't feel I
wouldn't feel guilty about not being
here with you guys it would be a loss
right like things things would slow down
we'd lose momentum right now things are
slowing down in my business that I'm not
happy with I would love to be further
along on a lot of product like I've got
so many exciting things that I have to
do I think just having the plan removes
the guilt before I had the plan I was
not nervous just anxious just one to
know how am I gonna make everything work
what is it what does it look like how
many days do I have him what what time
is gonna be awake to sleep kind of get
some work done at night maybe but I also
have you know I don't want to lose my
relationship with Nina right and so
Thursday night I'm gonna be able to get
some work done because the boys are
gonna go to sleep
Nina's gonna go to acupuncture he's
gonna have a late night so I can work
during that period and so I planned it
out and I know I've got X number of
hours to work and makes the work hyper
focused and it also means like the
conversation I had this morning with the
guy my team I cannot get to this until
two weeks from today which which eats me
up because I love being productive I
want to get work done but I don't feel
guilty about it
because I made the plane I'd rather
spend the time with my son then work on
that that project that project will
still be there for me in two weeks
so I think when you have a plane and
you've thought the things through I
think it not only removes a guilt I
think it allows you to be more present
to if I'm here right now feeling guilty
that I'm not with my son I'm not giving
you guys everything that I need to give
you and if I'm with Hayden and I'm
worried about projects that I have going
on then I'm not I'm not being fair to
him either and I'm just constantly
thinking business which isn't gonna help
my relationship with him so you're
physically there but you're not you're
not actually there which is where I
think a lot of people live not just on
summer breaks like this but just in
general in relationships like it's
something I talk to my wife about - it's
not it's not only about the the quantity
of time it's the quality of time just
just sitting together looking at a
couple sitting together as you know but
they're on their phones all day they're
not having a conversation that's not
actually time together at least for me
sure you're with that person physically
but but the it's the emotional
togetherness
that's not there so I think as much as
you can't have a plane unexpected things
will happen but have a plan so that you
know you're gonna be with your daughter
it's gonna take up this amount of time
the time that you're with your daughter
you want to make sure that there's
quality time at least you know if I'm
you how much quality time do you want to
have with your daughter what does that
look like for you quality time might be
reading the book doing an activity we're
gonna make some slime together go to the
pool a bunch of stuff what does quality
time look like for you how much do you
want to have during the day and then how
much time do you need for yourself to do
the projects that you're working on you
know you may not have to go all in on
one or the other and if I'm spending
here's the thing if I'm spending an hour
with Hayden as an example normally
during the week like on a weeknight or
something if I'm spending an hour with
him and that's part of the plan
I don't feel guilty about then I don't
feel guilty you like for this I don't
feel guilty I spent the whole morning
with him I don't feel guilty about
coming on for half an hour to talk with
you guys but when you are sitting there
not feeling present with your kids when
you should be and then you go and you do
work you're not gonna be present with
your work because you're thinking about
your kids then then you're just not
present anywhere and I think that's a
losing strategy make the schedule that
you are happy with yourself personally
forget about other people's judgments of
how much time you spend in that work or
with your kids because everybody else
will have some kind of opinion on you
and then just go execute that plan also
if you want to know what I think and
what other successful entrepreneurs
think about building confidence check
out my new 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next two hundred
fifty four days for free I will send you
a 30 second a five minute video in the
morning to help you build unstoppable
confidence the link is in the
description below if you want to be more
confident you need to surround yourself
with things that make you feel confident
realizing that any big endeavor is the
collection of a lot of small steps that
came before if you're doing work that
you love you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it raise your
standard Apple at the core is
value is that we believe that people
with passion can change the world not
one drop of myself work depends on your
it's something serene if you liked this
video check out the one I made on what
Jeff Bezos thinks about work-life
balance the link is right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I don't even like the phrase work-life
balance I think it's misleading